wait a minute what are you doing it's
all close to the same place no it does
not do
they sure don't
i think it would be fine really i feel
pretty good i feel pretty confident too
because i drove this for seven years
reverse commute from new york city to
springfield new jersey and i'm telling
you you're taking me to the [ __ ]
jersey shore and some bon jovi [ __ ] yeah
what i said okay you're right that would
have cost us 30 drock 30. and by the way
here's a key trash talk friends when you
take long turns in garage sales it's
[ __ ] over i'm telling you the whole
show would have been different because
we would have pulled up somebody even
walking around with the original
nintendo in the box look at this we've
been [ __ ] flying orlando right now
it's like five minutes no i'm telling
you there's no turn there that's another
seven miles before there's anywhere you
can go because that's called newark
airport you know it that's a [ __ ]
international airport
i'll help you i'm taking over now um
waze